the honeydew with y'all
thank you for your support here's ryan
sickler welcome back to the honeydew
with y'all y'all we're over here doing
it in the night pants studios i'm ryan
sickler you know that i want to thank
you all for your support you guys are
making a big difference a lot of you
really like the promo we put out
uh that was fun you know it's been
it's been great i asked and man you all
have [ __ ] delivered the stories are
amazing they keep coming we have already
a few in the in the bank that i can tell
you are pretty outrageous and uh this
week
is no different we're gonna hear a
pretty interesting stor occupation
former occupation
actually that i'm i'm kind of fascinated
by uh ladies and gentlemen please
welcome to the honeydew with y'all mike
frampton welcome
mike all right
thank you for being here and and let me
thank everybody again as well i'm
sincere uh when i say thank you for your
support
i do know that 60 is a lot for people i
know it's a bill i know it's you know
groceries i know
um so if you have it we appreciate it
and um if you sign up for a year you'll
save
i don't know it's 10 like you'll get
over a month free up of free episodes so
um
you know it's up to you keep your credit
cards updated if you want to stay for
the long haul because i get messages to
tell you to
to do that
anyway mike frampton uh mike first of
all thank you for being here on the show
um where are you in the world right now
where on planet earth are you
so i live in uh peterborough ontario uh
canada
um
i've been here my whole life
uh
except for like a stint to go to school
and back kind of thing but i've been
here kind of the whole time and where is
that where in canada what's the closest
city uh we're we're like an hour and a
half from toronto okay so you're east
yeah
um and how old are you
uh 35. all right and what do you do now
nothing well i'm chasing i'm chasing my
donut
breakfast truck coffee
idea so you bought it i always wanted a
diner and then covet hit and diners
weren't a thing anymore so oh okay so
you modified it to a break you haven't
you have i was like well i can include a
food truck now so let's see and so i
coveted kind of pushed me over the edge
and i finally uh i went and got the
truck but i got to figure out the rest
of it now so you do have a truck
yeah i got the trailer there yeah
yeah all right
got the fryers and the flat tops and all
the fun stuff and we're going to do the
i got people following me on instagram
and i'm going to do the build and i'm
going to do the unpack and i'm work i'm
working for free in two restaurants in
town uh with friends of mine to get kind
of the restaurant skills unpacked so
thursday friday or like prevent uh
professional uh development day kind of
thing and
i'm just going to chase it real hard
because it's what i want to do and i
mean bacon and eggs man
you're doing the right thing however
your email was very interesting unlike
anything i've seen
uh so let's talk about the the prior job
you left
tell me all
us all about it so
one i one of the only jobs i've done as
an adult i started at 22 and i did it
until october 4th
this year
um was clean up dead people
um i'm not a body remover i didn't go in
and drag them out in a bag
i
would spend
four to eight hours 12 hours five days
depending on what was going on with the
person how long they were dead what they
killed himself with how they died
what however they died was it all so
murder was included in that murder
suicide natural death
needle recoveries hoarders
anything gross anything grosser than
like people want to deal with yeah all
right let's start here what sort
how do you get into that how how does
that occupation come your way and then
before i forget i want to ask what
training do you get to do that no so
just get some bleach in a [ __ ]
closet i got thrown in the deep and
pretty hard right off the bat yeah
so
but but i got to make some mistakes with
someone else's business right off the
start so how do you all right then if
you get no there's no training it's just
get in there with this [ __ ] and clean it
up i'm sure there's tips and tricks but
wait how do you get into this oh there's
tricks yeah yeah how do you get into it
so i i went for paramedic in college um
and i did well all the way through until
about the end and
i ended up hurting my knee i'm not a big
guy i'm like 160 pounds and you know
they made you do a bunch of physical
[ __ ] that i wasn't i was happier
drinking and not training and getting
ready for it so
uh i [ __ ] that up a bit and then and i
was in thunder bay which is
uh 28 hours north of here or some [ __ ]
so like it was a big trek home i had to
find a job it wasn't going to be
paramedics uh
so i i saw this guy this crazy guy in
the paper talking about dead guys and i
just sent him a [ __ ] email and said
hey can i
come check this out this sounds fun and
he's like yeah it's it's good so he
trained me and
and i just just like a one-on-one he
didn't have a team there's not like
something
you all have ghostbuster outfits like
what are you you know what dude
sponsors are you sponsored it was a
really eccentric group of people
yeah i listen if there's anything i'm
sure of it's that a group of guys who
clean up dead bodies and [ __ ] no no you
didn't clean up bodies you can find us
on clean up crime scenes are an eclectic
group you can find us on imdb i think
because we had like a show in like 2009.
you did called
it was called grim sweepers and i think
we even got a pilot episode out
um
that's more than most comedians i know
yeah yeah so
yeah this is goddamn business
but like people were always like we
always had ghost hunters asking to come
with us and a bunch of you know there's
always eccentrics coming into the
woodwork to see what was up there's a
weird like obsession
how many
so this guy described him what was he
like older your age what was no no he's
probably 20 years 15 years older than me
and he'd been doing this a while this
was his [ __ ]
yeah been doing a long time and how many
how many people were on the team
oh there's probably
maybe eight of us now okay that's more
than i thought
but like he
he was just he was too much he was too
much and then i ended up finding a
contact through him
uh who was an ex-cop here in durham or
near durham which is like oshawa area
kind of
uh gmc town just outside of toronto and
uh
i've worked with him for the last
you know i was working with him with the
other company like he would send us work
and i'd work with this guy and i finally
one day said like listen these guys are
wild i can't like they were doing crazy
drugs and being being you know
just cowboys right so
i was out
and then i just ended up somehow getting
stuck and staying in it so
so what what's day one on the job do you
remember your very first
um cleanup
the very first one i ever did was a d
comp in whitby uh a second body
decomposing is that what that is
yeah so it was like an old it was an old
guy
who was masturbating on his couch and
had a heart attack on his what on his
couch like he was sitting at his couch
and we found like the lube and the the
dude once you're dead you can't hide it
so i see it all
so so he had his lube and he had his
like thing and he had the point on him
on the tv
he left all kinds of evidence
yeah yeah he dropped quick and he didn't
have any steps in him either it was like
stand up from the couch and drop to the
floor so and then he was there for
nine days or something man
he can't pretty much like nobody
if you don't have family or friends that
like that's why i talk to my friends a
lot
if you don't have family or friends that
check in on you and make sure you're
good
you can drop off the mac quick and like
it doesn't take long to go unnoticed for
a couple of days you know so
it's rough
man so what what was it like was it just
did it did it smell hard i have a
picture of it i have a picture
you can you can email it to us and we'll
post it
it's real nice it's uh
you can see my reflection in the puddle
of the guy and it's just he just spread
it across the concrete floor and we have
to pull all the uh the parquet tiles up
and they just pop out so that stuff
doesn't gross you out or or oh yeah yeah
i have a pretty good stomach uh i was
always in high school and stuff doing
[ __ ] thinking about it over here
like yeah yeah i've always had a you
know i gross out has always
made me howl like if someone pukes i
mean
[ __ ] me i laugh i can't and i think it's
and then it like i did the i did a in
high school i remember going to like a
morgue school trip that i signed up for
for a week you got to go to the
university and get to like go through
the morgue and see the dead bodies and
learn about the
we watched an autopsy and i'm like
eating lunch and [ __ ] so like i've
always been a little bit
you know
it's a lot it's more than a little bit i
think you have to be a bit eccentric to
chase eccentric [ __ ]
all right so
that's your first one let's talk about
what's the all right since you said
gross what's the grossest like if you're
saying it's gross i gotta believe it's
[ __ ] disgusting i mean they're all
groceries
dumpsters of like use diapers out of
houses and piss jugs and [ __ ] like got
like hundreds of gallons so like
it's all growth but well so we have
we've had hoarders um and once you hoard
yourself at your bathroom you got to
find a place to
put stuff
so
you start pissing water jugs which
aren't made to hold piss for more than a
couple months and then they break
because they're not meant to hold piss
uh you just pee in a popcorn is that
right urine breaks the plastic down well
in a water jug because they're meant to
hold water right but a coke bottle is
good because they're meant to hold like
an acidic drink right pee in that one
right
so
um but yeah we've done so many of those
where you just end up spending three
four days just dumping
hundreds of gallons of piss and
a lot of the d comps uh if they're
really bad like if they're weeks long
you end up [ __ ] the next morning
and smelling decomp in your [ __ ] no
yeah yeah no you spelled that body in
your [ __ ] well so i've had a couple guys
that i've got to work with me call me
they'd be oh what the [ __ ]
and i'm like what's up they're like i
took a [ __ ] this morning i was like yeah
and he's like it smells like yeah
you would die [ __ ]
i really do feel like i've taken a
couple of these [ __ ] around
with me you know get out of here dude
you could say we're suited i'm not like
bathing in it well you just smell it in
your face you can smell it for three
blocks in some cases because they're so
bad so like
i mean
oh in it
there's thousands of flies flying around
there's sludgy gross dead guys laying
like when the body removers take decomps
out they take between 60 and 90 pounds
of bones even if the guy was 500 pounds
because the rest of it melts out
oh is that what you meant by the huddle
is that what you meant by that
yeah yeah so if you're on the third
floor you're in the basement if you're
in a house if you're in a apartment as
long as you don't land on a seam which
has happened uh you puddle out
um if you go on a seam we had a girl
call us because she thought the guy's
sewer above broke and was dripping out
of his apartment because she was on the
third floor and he was on the fourth
and she was having uh she was in bed
and uh it ended up being a dead guy and
he finally like leaked through his bed
leaked through the seam in the floor in
the concrete and it was dripping on her
back while she was sleeping
so like she was
she was cute
dripped on this lady's back in her own
home
in an apartment in a downtown toronto
apartment downtown
yeah oh
man like you melt like especially if
you're fat like it just melts it's
butter right and if it's hot oh god i
didn't even think of that at least with
canada we have some cold winters so it
doesn't get as bad in the winter so what
do you do do you put like vicks vapo
wrong i'm gonna put under your nostrils
not to smell that no you smell it
you don't put anything under there i
mean no i don't take smelling salts to
my face no because then you taste
[ __ ] cherry or mint and i'd rather
taste that than [ __ ]
you think that [ __ ] [ __ ]
no no it is what it is it's the life man
it's uh it is quite a life well you have
a mask on like you're in a full face
like full tie back pp like gloves and if
there's maggots and bugs climbing around
you're really taped in and stuff because
they started biting and [ __ ] so do they
yeah oh you'll you'll leave and your
full face will be because you have a
mask that covers everything and
everything's sealed up and you'll leave
and you'll have little bloody leg prints
all over your face
mask because of the flies flying around
off the body
and then they'll land on your face
so but they've the flies have been so
bad in some jobs they sound like
someone's running a chainsaw beside your
head that's that many of them oh wild
black at the windows come on
yeah yeah it's crazy so give me some
specific ones let's hear something i
want to know ones that haunt you you
know ones that you you're like i this
one i remember this
let me let me i apologize for
interrupting but i don't know
yeah you've done so many of these that
i'm sure
that you've forgotten some which it
blows your mind but mathematically i'm
sure you have definitely forgotten some
but i'm also sure that some of them
really have hit home or
yeah so i'm gonna hear tom walk us
through some of those i feel like they
all define who who i am and the
decisions i've made and like watching
people live their lives the way they
choose to live home and rich poor and
everything in between is like
they'll die
and i get to clean them all up so like i
think i remember a good chunk of them
um
as far as gross out uh i'm just trying
to think so let me do that thanksgiving
while i was tiny bit earlier
you guys are coming up so you guys are
kind of like
yeah thanksgiving's coming up here in
the states
so um
this was in canada so it would have been
like two three months three weeks ago
for our thanksgiving but uh
there was a
newfish family in
uh oshawa that had called because their
dad had passed and he died at like 11
o'clock in the morning what you said a
what family
and they were they were new fees they
were like newfoundland oh okay okay i
didn't know that's what you call i
didn't know well i didn't either until i
until i showed up to this house so
they're like they're like island folk
and they're just like party and they're
the sweetest nicest people right
and i didn't realize any of this until i
showed up at the house and dad had
passed and he had an aneurysm or
something in bed just
bled out in bed so everyone was freaked
out they closed the door
but they're still making dinner like so
i showed up at 11 and she's getting like
the turkey ready and like your husband's
just passed but she was well she's
gotten i got 15 people coming over
so
they're all still coming to dinner
and i was like she's like so can you get
this done and out
that's your husband upstairs like i'll
do what i can so anyways so i show up at
the house this is on the phone talking
to her so i get to this house like an
hour later after the phone call and this
drunk guy pins me to my truck by my neck
and
that's that's how you get that's the
arrival this is the this is the show up
and he says uh he's like who are you
what are you doing why are you here and
i said uh like i'm just i i think i'm
here to clean up somebody like someone's
passed and
aneurysm in a bed is what i was told and
oh okay yeah yeah now he's hugging me
i'm like dude get the [ __ ]
so i told him i said you go clean up
your own dad like i don't give a [ __ ]
like
by my neck to my truck
right so they call him off like a dog
like the mom comes out and she's like i
don't remember his name but she's like
you know get get get back in the house
and he's just been drinking since dad
died
so she's like no please don't leave come
in he doesn't mean harm i was like okay
you know like jesus christ and we get
sent into crack houses and murder scenes
and [ __ ] so like i don't know what the
[ __ ] i'm walking into most of the time
so
that made me like i've never been
manhandled like this though yet
so
i uh i get in there clean it up and i
pack everything out and i go to leave
and she grabs me and she sits me down at
his [ __ ] spot
and what do you say he died
know where he eats oh and said she goes
it's thanksgiving you're not going
anywhere she's like we lost him we're
not losing two so i had to have [ __ ]
thanksgiving dinner with these new
things no you did not i'm drinking like
molson expo
yeah with that and eating drinks like
you just died upstairs and where's the
body right now while you're having
thanksgiving so the body got pulled just
as i was rolling in it was going out in
like a in a hearse or whatever they
usually just go to the funeral home or a
hospital depending on the time of day
um i feel like i'm talking to the screen
i should talk to the thing um but yeah
they usually go to the funeral home and
then the funeral but they don't do any
of the cleanup right so anything left
behind or anything technically not
connected to the gross skeleton is what
they say i think
this is mine you know so so i cleaned
this guy up uh he just had blood he had
something ruptured in his neck in his
sleep and he woke up bleeding and
coughing and that was it he didn't
didn't even get into bed but to have to
sit in his seat and eat his meal it was
uh that that one [ __ ] me up for a bit
yeah that would [ __ ] me up yeah yeah so
that was it was really neat and they're
really loving and kind but then i have
to listen to you know three and a half
hours of [ __ ] family stories about
the guy that just died that i just
cleaned up
now i'm absolutely taking that [ __ ] with
me and i'm like don't tell me their
names don't tell me their [ __ ] cat's
name i don't want to know because it
haunts the [ __ ] idiot like
you you i scraped scrapes ceilings of
brains and then i have to listen to the
morning families on top of it it's like
okay now now i get like two heavy things
happen right you get the back story
because they all just want to unload on
somebody and say well i want the guy
who's going to hang out in the house and
scrape them up you
so okay
let's walk through uh
i do want to hear more stories but i
want to walk through a scenario i know
you get a call or you get assigned this
job and you go there and
the families in the [ __ ] they don't
leave it depends on what happened and it
depends on the family and it depends on
the morning process like some people
don't want anything to do with it some
people need to see that the guy actually
died
uh some people want to rob them of all
their [ __ ] like dad's got some nice
stuff and i don't want to lose the tv so
they're there and watching you know like
i call those vultures they're the worst
um and you see him you know him right
away i know oh yeah it's like oh i
walked his dog once and he had a brand
new tv for me on the wall you know but
it's usually family fighting over stupid
[ __ ] if i'm not into that man i just i'm
here for the can we wait until i get the
dead guy out of the house and then you
guys [ __ ] around with the stupid [ __ ] so
you get you get there and do you know
what you're walking into or is it a
surprise every time uh usually i get
like you know
d comp suicide murder
and then if i get a murder or a stabbing
or something like that i usually can
find it like in the news um because you
know they're all usually all over the
gory [ __ ] suicides you don't hear about
ever and there's nine suicides for every
murder here in canada for sure hands
down more than that more than that
so
we have a suicide issue here suicides
and overdoses are we don't have a murder
problem although we do have murders but
nothing like the states so yeah
um so what um so you get there and
you're you're seriously scraping brains
from suicides and what you've seen
myself listening to the honey dude
that's the only way to lead up the dead
it's why i rely on my comedy so much
because most of the time i was working
by myself so it's just headphones in and
[ __ ] you don't get to it and
if it's a shotgun it makes a hell of a
mess
so
you gotta just
you just gotta get through it but yeah
you know if i'm called to a house or an
apartment or whatever if it has to be
done right away and the suicides
typically did because usually they took
people by surprise and usually
or at least some of the time it was
someone young or someone you know like
we get a lot of young suicide so people
don't want to wait until tomorrow for
their kids so there's a lot of 2 a.m
cutting them mattresses or
scooping out tubs or cleaning up shotgun
suicides or and these poor families are
just blindsided but it's in their house
they
what just happened in that room is well
they have to come to terms with the fact
that they lost their kid yeah in their
home and then have to live in that house
after that i get the [ __ ] out of that
house
yeah i would too i would not be able to
stay
no people ask me about hauntings and
stuff and i don't believe in that stuff
because i'd be haunted as [ __ ] if i did
yeah you would they'd be like yeah yeah
i'm [ __ ] them out of me right
yeah so they're coming with me but i i i
i don't believe in that stuff but there
there's uh there's a weird feeling to
the death stuff so yeah
murders like what
in the home oh yeah like and anything
like over drugs or
jilted x's or
um
uh a lot of family [ __ ]
like one of the last ones i did in the
summertime uh this [ __ ] he was
like the
a lot of times it's like the kid and
he's been brought home
because he has mental health or i keep
saying he because it's usually
gonna say it sounds like it's usually
males it's usually now um but the last
one i remember he he came upstairs like
he was living in the basement and mom
and dad were upstairs and he ripped the
banister off of the
like the spindle off of the staircase
like a wooden spindle yeah just just
tore it off and killed his mom with it
no
just with that and i was like what the
[ __ ] and then went after his dad with a
kitchen knife he stabbed his sister
killed her holy like it was just oh yeah
he just so he had been lying about going
to university or some [ __ ] and finally
like it was graduation day and guess who
hasn't been going to university for four
years and taking mom and dad's money
and he thought the way out of it i guess
it was 20 years
but like that kind of [ __ ] happened all
the time people wiping out families
so it is mostly family related
you're not seeing stranger i'm sure you
do but
it's the smaller percentage compared to
people who know one another prime based
stuff like the guys running coke out of
their house and then the bigger coke
dealers show up and be like hey what are
you doing they cut them up into pieces
and [ __ ] you know like jesus you've
you've dealt with that you've seen
bodies yeah we had a guy cut up into
like oh i got to that job and they
pulled 11 body bags and i was like [ __ ]
me how many people were in there he's
like oh two
oh my and i was like oh
yeah yeah
so they just put them in the tub and and
that guy was just running like
i mean it sounds like a lot of drugs but
it was like 20 grand or less that's not
a lot of drug money it's not 20 grand is
not when it comes to drug not for your
life your life's more than enough
yeah oh and i wonder if they cut him up
while he was alive or when he was dead
that's the thing you don't know or do
you know can you tell that kind of [ __ ]
you can tell us some stuff because like
if you die in place like the masturbator
guys and or anyone with a heart attack
the ones that drop or like a lot of
people dying taking a [ __ ] a lot like
when you wake up in the morning take a
walk around then have your [ __ ] don't
that right i've heard it don't go to the
toilet don't go bed to toilet that's a
heart attack waiting to happen is it i
keep telling my dad that yeah
i hear that i've heard you get out
stretches and [ __ ] you know we move
around a bit
the number of people that wrap
themselves around toilets and just have
heart attacks and then they can't get up
because their hearts are poached and
they you know and they drop and then
now you're there for how long you're
there right but
uh other ones run around the house if
you're stabbed
stabbed or shot or something violent
you're trying to get away so it's like a
chase right
um i i can think of one we did last
winter where this guy was on blood
thinners for like a health problem
and
he um
went to a tool shed in the back of his
property maybe a hundred yards away from
his house
and he cut he was a hunter uh and he cut
himself on a broad head that he had like
an arrow
on a shelf he just nicked like right
here
nothing crazy but because he was on
blood thinners
he we chased the blood all the way back
to his house
into the basement and he made it to the
bottom of the stairs where he just kind
of made a nest for himself and curled up
in a little ball and died because he
lost he was 33.
how what what the [ __ ] was he taking so
long to lose all that blood
the blood thinners he blooded so quick
so he only had a hundred like that he
had 100 yards in him and that was it
bled out and he got so sleepy by the
bottom of the stairs he just kind of
curled up
and i was like what's up with this
[ __ ] nest and they're like we think
that he just lost enough energy that he
was trying to stay warm enough to get
help but he couldn't get to the phone
and he was like
an hour from me up north which is
nowhere
so like you so that kind of thing we've
had a lot of people blow their [ __ ]
out what do you mean like
like rupture right like uh cancer or
whatever the did they get these ruptures
i hear dr drew talked about this all the
time you got to be careful right
and they get these rub shares and they
bleed all over your place what do we got
to be careful with putting [ __ ] in your
ass or we've had people buy sex toys
we've had people yeah
hold on you've you've had
oh this is a good one this is a good one
come on
he's got to take him
out yeah
yeah so okay so this was like 2 2014.
uh we showed up at this house
beautiful house uh he was like a
catholic school board trustee or already
sounds devious
yeah i mean high up though like the
guy's living in a six bedroom you know
but myself divorced you know alone
enough in this house and
we go in and it looks like a regular
house and then we go down in the
basement
and it is like medieval times dungeon
and this guy has
sex toys all over the walls
and he has died in a sex swing
and i guess what ended up happening was
he had hired prostitutes to do things to
him in the sex swing and he had heart
attack in the swing and they just pieced
out
yeah
they were like they were like
the jose stay you know the hoes are not
sticking around for that [ __ ] there's no
way
i think they got caught too
there's probably enough dna to track
their ass down yeah well when we walked
in it was just like rows of
at least 50 dildos on this wall and
they're huge
and you're just like [ __ ] how like
one guy he was by himself in this house
so he was just hiring these people to
come in and just wreck him
so but he didn't know that
he had a heart attack okay he had the
heart attack but they saw him dropping
like in the swing he's leading him in
the swing he's sitting there swinging
for weeks dead swinging for weeks just
hanging just hanging dripping into the
floor this episode
[Laughter]
okay so
i have another good one if you want to
keep it i want to hear well yeah we've
got time
okay cool so i've got one called
comesicles and if i tell any of my
friends about comsicles they're like
dude the other picture bring the picture
up show them a picture which i'm not
going to do but like
everyone knows about this so
i don't get grossed out easy obviously
um
comsicles was it's in oshawa i'm not
going to like hide where it was because
asha was like a bit of a [ __ ] and
like [ __ ] oshawa but
the
guy's apartment was right near the
police station i do a ton of police
cleaning um we've done we had contracts
for like police cars and the drunk tank
and stuff like that so i knew the area
and then they said oh just down the
street this guy died go check it out we
went and checked it out
and it was like this guy was painting
nazi german tanks like miniatures
just like on the side you know a hobby
yeah yeah yeah and you just like had
them on shelves yeah them on shelves
yeah yeah and i don't go into jobs
not in full ppe because like you never
know what people have and what's flying
around and stuff so i'm all suited up
anyways
and i kind of like glide across this
guy's living room carpet
and i'm like what the [ __ ] and i started
looking around and dude this place is
harvard income what do you mean
alvard he has been jacking off in this
apartment since i was four
and just leaving it not wiping it up
well his main one was in a computer
chair with those arms like the black
computer chair and he would just sit
there he didn't have a computer
i'll tell you about that in a second
this is a really good one too um but he
would just sit there and jack off and
then when he finished he would finish
off to the right and it would drip off
the side of the chair
and he made
it's like comes the life
or whatever the [ __ ]
so it was just dripping off the channel
what the [ __ ] is that and we found like
dildos in his fork drawer and this guy
was like drawer he's got dildos
just wrapped up
broken wrapped up in towels right next
to the chopsticks right there yeah we
used them to hold the door open
like to get all the [ __ ] because we have
to clear into this guy's entire
apartment
dildos door stoppers yeah oh we said
like clock the door open let's go
yeah
because they were all broken there was
like fire
there's wires
[Music]
yeah yeah so i don't know how he broke
them um but so this guy's porn
collection was in layers maybe 40 30
layers
uh and it was like a towel and then a
bunch of porn magazines cut out and then
a cheat and then porn magazine cutouts
and then a pillowcase and then porn
magazine cutouts
and like layered like that right and
what he was doing was like finishing on
that layer and then folding it up and
throwing it away so he had like layers
of porn options
do you understand what i mean like you
would finish on this layer and then roll
up the blanket and throw it out and then
like come and go he'd jerk it and then
once that was like the internet with
towels and porn magazines
like he just layered
he's like dude this guy's laptop what
are you doing so he was all prepared and
[ __ ] too like he didn't even get through
that exactly
your chair and died before
him
oh he didn't get through the stack but
he got through a lot of it because it
was crumpled up in the corner in a big
[ __ ] fire [ __ ] did it smell in there
oh it stunk like [ __ ] like
like
pool water like those trees it smelled
like like bleachy it was awful it was
awful um but [ __ ] we laughed that day
god damn like it was the most important
day is
the difference between you and me
i would have quit i don't i've been like
what is that nah i'm done problem
yeah
well that one was that one was
that one was wild so that one sticks
like that one was really like a good
grossery one no pun intended it sticks
yeah that is a disgusting one like
there's
how many how many times can you finish
in a 12 hour stay at a police cell but
if i live in the [ __ ] house and i
just come all over the place it fills up
pretty quick how many you never find a
woman like that you never go to a
woman's place and she's got a dungeon
no no no
you'll find a dildo you'll find a
vibrator you'll find like
50 shades of gray or whatever the [ __ ]
in the counter thing right that's it
like
guys
animals animals some really wild
disgusting [ __ ] savage pigs yeah yeah
yeah and they don't even need other
people to be like that
stick stuff in them yeah holy [ __ ] i've
heard uh tom segura and then on the ymh
stuff talk about sounding and stuff we
found sounding things on multiple i
don't even know what that is what's
sounding like when they put the thing in
the tip of the penis on why aren't we no
no no no this is like a thing it's like
a
so it's like a pen it's like this it's
like a pen
and it grows in the urethra
and they do this like it's a pouring
thing it's not it's like like cleaning
it like bottle brushing thing yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and you can go up
and down engage and i guess it's fairly
common in at least we see it a lot in
like the gay community when we do
suicides and stuff they
i for years i was like what the [ __ ] are
these things and they were sounding
equipment
nope
no i i had a girlfriend tell me that she
had an ex-boyfriend that liked when she
took her pinky nail and dug it in his
urethra this is the sound i
to this day it angered me
it bothered me and i have never
forgotten that and that's been
minimum 15 years ago she told me that
and it's
someone recently i swear we went to a uh
awake a sort of it was not really awake
but more of a
a celebration of life for a really good
friend who had passed with cancer and
her name's heidi and she came up to me
and she goes you know what i remember
about working with you and i go what and
she goes the day that sandy told you i
go you're gonna say that's that
fingernail [ __ ] she goes yup she goes it
bothered you i still think about it it
dr
i can't even with that kind of [ __ ] man
oh yeah it sticks
it's
yeah so when they start talking about
like the ymh shows and stuff all that
gross edge stuff and their people are
posting like
vomit and gagging and stuff to it i'm
just watching like just howling i love
it just eating it's cereal and [ __ ] over
there
having chicken wings and watching the
show yeah dude
i can't wait for the next one i can't
wait for the next one so
that's like five months
well the next the next live ymh because
it's just like it's my vein it's in my
it's like in my wheelhouse so funny you
are the demo for that show yeah yeah
yeah yeah once i found them i was like
oh [ __ ] and yeah when i heard about the
program
penises touching one another i was like
oh it ain't for me you know
that's the [ __ ] tom does when you sit on
that show he shows you those [ __ ]
videos you're like i love christ
i love the two of you guys together too
i just watched the two bears uh the
other day that you were recovering from
birth that was so much fun yeah and it
was so good so good so but uh yeah well
i gotta say dude this this was
just we have not had an episode like
this i have not heard a job like this i
i told you before uh off mike
off camera when we were talking that i
remember living in baltimore and there
was so much
you know violent crime there and and
murder and all this that there was a
company that would come in and they
would clean up the scene for these poor
people that had to you know again live
in their home with it or whatever it was
you don't want to walk outside and see
your your husband's blood all over the
sidewalk or whatever the [ __ ] it is so
people don't realize right like if you
shoot yourself in the head i mean or
whatever right but if you kill yourself
like they think the cops take that [ __ ]
if anything the cops come in and trash
your [ __ ] and try to figure out who did
it or whatever yeah and it's like no he
killed himself and then they leave but
it's like well it's like now we'll clean
it up yeah yeah exactly and then
insurance companies a lot of times
especially with insurance up here they
just they just drop you they don't they
don't cover the suicide stuff so
so then people are just like left
holding it so they're paying for two
funerals basically because you know it's
not gonna be cheap it's not the end of
the world up here i i know the people in
the states make a killing on the money
but up here it's not like that but
um
yeah it's not cheap to deal with and
it's not fun to deal with and it's not
something you want to deal with before
you do your funeral and [ __ ] either so
well before i go i do want to ask you
what
what was the last straw for you then
this had to affect your mental state
your mental health your
you're just yeah on everything is
yeah i've got like uh i got uh you know
therapy and trying to do the diet thing
and be you know aware of stuff you know
i'm trying to do the self-care thing
uh and covid for me started here in
march
and we got a contract to do police stuff
uh i got a chance because the suicide
rate the last what nine months much
higher were you dealing with a lot more
of that during no i would say less and i
think because people are afraid of
something that's outside of their head
so there's this boogie man outside so
that takes the focus away
and then i think when they settle in and
this goes away and they don't have
someone else to blame for the condition
that they're in or whatever now they're
back to where they were right
but i also think people are drinking and
doing drugs and misbehaving more than
they ever have
uh so i think it's just a matter of time
till we start seeing the [ __ ] stuff
start hitting but uh
yeah well good for you for getting out
of it and getting your but yeah i had to
i had to get it we did fogging we did um
so we have these machines of fog
disinfectant so every day i would just
drive and took about an hour to get to
the first station and i would drive
four or five police stations every day
and just fog police cars with chemical
and this thing sounds like a vacuum so
you're just hauling around this vacuum
and you know my shoulders were sore
because it's all full it's full like
four gallons worth of chemical you're
just hauling around spraying [ __ ]
and it
the drone of that machine and just being
trapped in that mask all the way through
summer
in full tie back and [ __ ] so you're just
cooking and i'm 35 i was like this is
i'm i'm just done with this you know
like it's
it's it was a it's a battle to do every
job it's a struggle to do every job
there's got to be something more
positive out there for me
i've always liked diners so about two
years ago i started making donuts on the
side just to do something positive and
now i'm chasing donuts and coffee from
the dead to doughnuts man that's just
that's the one from
death to donuts that should be the name
of your [ __ ] food truck yeah
yeah well so i'm tragically dipped
um because that's good
because uh the lead singer of the
tragically hip his memorial was like the
first day in february when i was
starting donuts
and when i found out he died like we
knew he died but then i was listening to
this memorial i was just bawling
crying making my first batch of donuts
and i was like i'm gonna name i'm gonna
tie because he's like true canadiana
from for music and stuff so
i i wanted the tragically hip tie so i
thought that was good but like i i don't
want to clean dead people up for another
13 years and if i didn't get out i
wasn't going to get out yeah you weren't
because people are not going to stop
dying
oh do you have a second you want to see
that tattoo oh yeah yeah you said you
had a tattoo i do want to see this
tattoo yeah it's pretty good
so it's a grim reaper with a mop and i
got it year one because i thought
because i thought i was gonna do this
forever so now i have a grim reaper
stuck on me for the rest of my life but
i don't know can you see it there yeah i
can see it
so he's got a mop and he's cleaning up
some blood it's all bad ass and stuff
but
probably shouldn't have leaned into it
i'll lean right in i'm going to put some
donuts on there too just to
give me um we have some time give me a
couple more crazy ones i'll really want
to hear some more stories over the years
i've taken a lot of friends on jobs with
me when i need a hand if it's a bigger
job i can handle
if
if someone's not available i have a
buddy of mine that lives up the street
i've known him since kindergarten
and so i got this one
he'll just roll with you he just just
comes and hangs there
and i have two i have two buddies that i
have a bunch of buddies that did that
with me over the years but um
you know they get paid cash for the day
and they get to see something cool and i
get to have someone help me carry the
[ __ ] out
so we did this job here locally in
peterborough
um
and it was like a hoarding situation the
guy had like really bad uh i guess
depression uh or something
hoarded up his house to the point where
like i was saying earlier they start
[ __ ] in the sinks and the tubs and
the toilets let me ask you about that
you said basically what they're doing is
they they then will hoard themselves and
back themselves into a room right once
they're there if you let them go if you
let them go
like the living room because they're
just all of a sudden that they're just
piling [ __ ] there's no more space well
the kitchens will go and then it's like
well what are they eating and so then
it's all fast food containers and then
the horde builds faster because they're
throwing their wendy's on the floor and
stuff and
um so we had something like that this
guy was drinking so there's bottles
everywhere and uh we do a lot of times
there's needles and drugs and things
like that
so you've got to be careful when you're
digging through those hordes because you
don't want to get stuck with something
um so we did we were doing that kind of
thing we got to this house it was bad
there's there was piles
my buddies corey hadn't seen anything
like this
he says to me
what am i looking at like what is what's
in the sink and i said that [ __ ]
he goes no it's not and i was like well
the guy's hoarded at his bathroom over
there where would he go like
there's no shame
you don't get to stop [ __ ] so if you
hold your bathroom you got to figure
that out
home depot buckets we had people get so
desperate they just
cut a hole in the floor in their living
room and just [ __ ] into the basement no
yeah would be just that well then i have
to go take the [ __ ] basement out
right so we have these farm shovels and
we're like cow shoveling [ __ ] out of the
basement [ __ ]
we've had a couple that did that where
they just took a sawzall and just cut a
[ __ ] hole and just down the it goes
you know
so anyways so this one i can't you guys
with this episode this guy fills his
sink he fills his toilet filled his
toilet to the point where like this guy
had to [ __ ] stand on the side of his
tub and on his sink to get over the [ __ ]
pile to get the [ __ ] to land on top no
i had to take a contractor bag and it
filled it the whole thing all the way
down
and then we had to push the bullet [ __ ]
over in the bag to get that
so this guy dies obviously he's not dead
in the bed so we have to do this decomp
the decomp was the best part of the
whole [ __ ] job because there's like
rat infested poo everywhere everything's
filled with [ __ ]
it's hot so we have a dumpster there is
this in a house an apartment
this is in a makeshift apartment in the
minister's
house
because he was he was like a church guy
and he was taking care of one of these
people with this depression i'm like
that's not taking care of [ __ ]
just letting him be at your house and
[ __ ]
drowning and poo and alcohol right so
so there was so much feces and stuff it
had rotted his kitchen out it had rotted
his floorboards out there was rats
infested
how do you stay in there and not get
sick how do you smell that all day long
without getting
humans are pretty resilient i mean i've
seen people live in you can breathe that
in all day long i don't think you should
obviously you should yeah but but he he
that guy lived you know and we do
hoarders that have been hoarding for
years that they live in moldy shitty
gross flooded out you know
people people are
resilient so
so we get to the bedroom do the decount
best part of the whole job
you know
break the bed down get the gross stuff
out take the mattress and stuff out
and then there's this
bucket like a home depot bucket and it
has
what looks like a lid on it
but what it was was more like a crust
and so it was full of [ __ ]
and we had been cleaning [ __ ] for the
last day and a half so you would think
that the bucket that you're just about
to grab cory
is full of [ __ ] too because everything
else was full of [ __ ]
but he thought it was a lid so he just
grabbed the bucket and i went flying
full gear passed him pushed past him
he's like dude what the [ __ ] like where
are you going i didn't say a word i just
ran at the heads because i knew what he
just did
he just unloaded the worst because this
bucket had a crust so the poo was
rotting inside the bucket
he the second he grabbed the bucket the
the the [ __ ] stopped
and then
rot but it had been like fermenting so
it smelled like [ __ ] and salami and
oh it was and so he didn't know what he
had done
and he saw me take off and he goes where
are you going and the second he said
where are you going he started dry
heaving because they punched them right
in the throat and even through all that
even through all that gear oh yeah yeah
even with the filters and the
it was so hard like
my eyes then like [ __ ] it was bad it was
like that was one of the worst smells
i've ever had
that that poo bucket for whatever reason
i don't know what was in it but god damn
and it just
it just hit it's like 43 degrees out and
it's great
have you ever cleaned up um a scene of
someone you knew
um
i've cleaned up like a scene where i've
run into someone i've recognized but
that's about it like you know their
friend's brother died or my
friend of yours you ever have to clean
up a friend's parent no i don't think
like this i think that would [ __ ] me up
too much yeah that was something i
always said like i would find some help
but i don't think i could do it on my
own
that would be too much i think you know
like i couldn't do friends or family i
don't think
i'd want to help but like that would be
a lot
so if this stuff doesn't gross you out
i'm curious what does what turns your
stomach
is something weird like peanut butter or
just some regular old [ __ ] like what
what makes you be like uh
i don't know that i have found much yet
do you think you could be a surgeon do
you think you cut something open would
that bother you that way
i think more the responsibility of like
keeping someone alive would [ __ ] with me
right when i was doing it
yeah what am i gonna do they're dead i'm
not gonna make it worse i'm just gonna
get rid of the bad
um
even with paramedics like keeping people
alive i think that would have done more
maybe as much damage as what i've done
to myself doing this so
what like what are you hired but you're
not hired by the county or regulated
like do you just pull up
it all depends so i mean where are you
putting human feces where do you go to
dispose of all this stuff
so it depends on what you're cleaning up
if it's a horde you just drop a big
dumpster right on the driveway and fill
it up and then where does that dumpster
go
depends on where you are but sometimes
landfill sometimes they have a
specialized disposal we have hazardous
waste drop-offs for like needles and
stuff and then you have specialized
disposal pickups uh
around depending on where you are in the
province
they can do site pickups so if you're on
like a bad decomp you just box it up in
these
special boxes and then they go on a
truck that's refrigerated and then they
go supposedly go to a incinerator or
some [ __ ] i don't know they charge a lot
for it so they better go to an
incinerator
so
but uh yeah most of the time like a lot
of time it just goes down the sewer like
if you die in your tub or whatever i
just grab a bucket and then do the
you know empty the tub
so you mean if you just leak out in the
tub
yeah people find it all the time there's
a lot of there's a lot of people that
just
i had this is a good one actually
speaking of tubs uh i had a guy i
cleaned up three times
uh over
five years what do you mean
so the first time he took he was drunk
and he tried to kill himself and he took
a hammer and a wrench and he like itchy
and scratching himself like his own
bled
everywhere and didn't die
didn't die but really [ __ ] himself up
really [ __ ] himself up and then maybe
nine months later i got a phone call
to go to a suicide attempt
and he had taken same address i was like
oh no this address and i pulled up to
the house i was like oh this is the
itching scratchy eye and then he had
taken a handful of pills and climbed
into the tub and the pills didn't kill
him but they like incapacitated him
enough that he couldn't get out of the
tub so he sat in a tub in the water for
four days to the point where his hands
were starting to like de-glove
and like the skin was starting to
separate because just laying in water
for days
right
he was alive yeah like the souls of his
feet were starting to come off and [ __ ]
like he was alive but he wasn't in great
shape
um and then a year and a half after that
i cleaned him up on his couch and he
took a handful of pills again don't take
pills pills are [ __ ] up you know like
don't kill yourself but don't kill
yourself yeah yeah but i mean i wish
that was that easy i think but
well yeah people choose ways to do it
and it's just like what do you
what are you doing like did you
i don't want anyone to think about doing
it but take a second and think if you're
going to do it
like there's no reason to suffer like
that holy [ __ ] like we had guys drink a
plant
like a weed be gone or whatever you call
it like a wheat
and it doesn't work
but it melts your insulin
tear your insides up yeah yeah so like
we had a guy drink a half a gallon of
that weed
killer
didn't kill him
and then he grabbed his it and it hurt
his inside so much that this guy plugged
a circular sign and just started going
to town no
part of his hand cut his hand off went
down his thigh went across his groin
went across his stomach and then finally
bled out but after minutes it would have
been like it would have been him just
like struggling to die oh
and so like that kind of stuff is like
oh what the [ __ ] and then you see oh he
drank his own hand off but he was
melting from the inside out so like what
do you do
right like you've you've already [ __ ]
yourself long-term
you're panicking to get you know
what do you do how do you make sense of
that you're already in shock so like i
don't judge people on how they act or
how they choose to do stuff but like
there's been some stuff that people
choose it's like [ __ ] hell
like i wouldn't have thought of that one
or i wouldn't have done this right you
know
but
it sucks it sucks
but and then everyone's left behind that
you know everyone that doesn't die has
to deal with it so
then you're over there asking for more
[ __ ] stuffing at thanksgiving dinner
and [ __ ]
i mean that'll stick with me the rest of
my life so i i'm better
but that was [ __ ] like don't put me at
his spot put me at like the kids table
or something i'll hang out with them
give me a little bag
at that dad's spot
and then like now they're all directing
their attention at my spot to tell me
all the stories and it's like oh [ __ ]
there's the trauma i'm taking home with
me you know
tell me i'll bet all the kids would you
you know
well mike thank you uh for coming on
this seriously has been it's been one of
the most interesting episodes i've ever
done
uh quite an awkward i was worried you
have
i was worried i was worried to hear the
stories but i'm glad i hung in there
because i knew you had i knew you were
going to tell me the worst of the worst
that's what it always is for uh those
kind of jobs so
i mean what do you yeah sure well thank
you again um i really appreciate you
coming on
and for those of you out there watching
uh listening
if you or someone you know has a story
that needs to be heard please submit at
honeydewpodcast gmail.com
uh we'll go through them vet them and
hopefully we'll get to do a story
together make sure you got your credit
cards up to date subscribe for a year
save some money and we'll talk to y'all
next week
[Music]
you